pendant plus de sept heures ils ont fait
face ils ont tout vu tout entendu de
cette reconstitution
mais la vérité qu'ils espéraient est
enfin là les parents d'alexia sa soeur
son beau frère ont porté johnatan d'aval
jusqu'au bout jusqu aux aveux complets
nous a demandé me pardonne bien qu'ils
agissent qu'il est justifié que c'était
impardonnable et vous pouvez être captée
par don de l'espagne par rapport à
alexia on sait pas c'est pas c'est
tellement dur pour l'instant on l'a aimé
voilà principal pour l'instant c'est
d'avoir la vérité le pardon ça viendra
un peu plus tard
ça aurait été un immense gâchis depuis
le début de cette affaire est
aujourd'hui au moins il fait un grand
pas vers la vérité c'est un souffle un
vrai soulagement
tout avait commencé à l'aube au domicile
de johnatan et alexia d'aval un quartier
entièrement bouclé à l'intérieur
johnatan ce livre ce soir-là d'octobre
2010 est alexis avait exigé un rapport
sexuel elle qui prenait à l'époque un
traitement pour la fertilité la dispute
bascule dans les coups les aveux de
johnatan colts enfin au constat des
médecins légistes qui l'aurait frappé le
visage de sa femme contre un mur en
béton dans la descente d'escalier il
l'aurait ensuite parce qu'elle
continuait à évidemment à la criée elle
se plaignait il lui aurait asséné dit-il
entre cinq et dix coups de poing au
niveau du visage et ensuite il a remis
mais le geste qu'il aurait accompli ce
soir-là ans en l'étranglant pendant
environ quatre minutes de façon continue
l'acte 2 de la reconstitution a lieu
dans cette forêt à quelques kilomètres
du domicile
johnatan sort un mannequin de son
véhicule et le déplace sans problème
il n'y avait donc pas de complices
restent le corps calciné d'alexia
johnatan se retire quelques minutes puis
à vous
c'était un des derniers blocages encore
de 2 notamment s'agissant du déroulement
de tous les faits de cette terrible
affaire est effectivement voilà l'idée
parvenir à la vérité que janet ann
reconnaissent la crémation
c'est bien il faut aussi parvenir à la
vérité de la chose suivante pourquoi
quelqu'un comme johnatan d'aval que rien
ne présageait à finir devant une cour
d'assises a tué son épouse
pourquoi il restait un chaînon manquant
dans cette enquête
il est désormais identifié en fin
d'après-midi johnatan d'avaler reparti
vers la maison d'arrêt de dijon